usa today usa today life in particular
had gotten a little bit of trouble
yesterday because they published an
article and a tweet thread
that appeared to try to normalize
pedophilia
some of us on the right you know hate to
say i told you so
have called it for years
that the left is inevitably going to try
to normalize pedophilia not just because
they are degenerate perverts that's not
that's not why actually
that's not the only reason why but
because the logic of the left on the
sexual revolution requires them to
normalize pedophilia
and that's exactly what this usa today
piece did
the article title was
what the public keeps getting wrong
about pedophilia
you know that much put upon minority
pedophiles you know them there was a
professor who was just fired for trying
to normalize pedophilia tried to
redefine pedophiles as as maps
minor attracted persons so here's what
usa today says what we think we know we
think we know what a pedophile is
there's a lot of misunderstanding in
recent decades the science on pedophilia
has improved one of the most significant
findings is that pedophilia is likely
determined in the womb though
environmental factors may influence
whether someone acts on an urge to abuse
the evidence suggests it is inborn it's
neurological said james cantor a sex
researcher and expert on pedophilia
could you imagine being an expert on
pedophilia that's
not the kind of expertise you want when
most of the public thinks of pedophilia
they assume it's synonymous with child
sexual abuse a pedophile is an adult
who's sexually attracted to children but
not all pedophiles abuse kids and some
people who sexually abuse kids are not
pedophiles
pedophiles may not have control over the
fact that they're attracted to kids but
they are responsible for what they do or
don't act on says ann salter who's
another pedophile expert
usa today deleted this thread they kept
the article up there they retitled it
they got a lot of backlash
and they got a lot of backlash from
conservatives
somewhat justifiably because they
clearly are trying to normalize
pedophilia but i actually think
conservatives reacted a little too
quickly here
because i think that the
principle
that usa today is describing is actually
extremely conservative and i think the
principle that usa today is describing
actually undermines
not just the left argument on
extremely creepy sex stuff like
pedophilia but the left's whole argument
on the sexual revolution
what what usa today has done in this
article almost certainly unwittingly
is defended sexual repression and
conversion therapy on january 17th tens
of thousands of men are going to start
living a different life that different
life is going to help them turn away
from eating too much drinking too much
and spending too much time in the office
it's going to challenge them to stop
ignoring their wives children or friends
by putting a pause on their social media
turning off netflix youtube and sports
men if you desire freedom true freedom
from attachments freedom to be a better
husband a better father and a better man
for others i invite you to check out
exodus 90.com michael starting january
17th exodus 90 will take men on a 90-day
journey through the book of exodus
taking them back to the fundamentals of
the faith prayer self-denial and
brotherhood tens of thousands of men
from all around the world will start
exodus 90 this year on january 17th 2022
to journey through lent and end on
easter sunday to date more than 50 000
men have done exodus 90 99 reported
experiencing greater freedom i invite
you to join them on this life-changing
journey head on over to exodus 90.com
michael to sign up set your start date
for january 17th and invite a few
friends to journey with you that is
exodus nine zero dot com slash michael
there there were two kinds of backlash i
think to this article the only one we
really saw was the conservative backlash
but think about what what usa today is
saying here they're saying pedophilia is
natural
natural meaning it's with you from the
moment you're born it's not something
that's learned necessarily but something
it's a sexual orientation
right that's the difference between a
sexual desire that maybe you develop
over time and a sexual orientation
that's with you from the moment of birth
and you can't change it now is
pedophilia
inborn natural a sexual orientation i
don't know
maybe maybe not that's kind of secondary
to the point
what usa today is saying is
even if
a sexual desire is inborn
even if you're born this way which was
the left's entire argument on the lgbt
movement and ultimately why they
redefine marriage
you still should repress some of those
desires
but hold on we were told if you have a
sexual desire from birth and you can't
change it it's immutable then you should
not repress it that it's very harmful
and unhealthy to repress that desire
that it's immoral to ask someone to
repress that desire because they're born
this way now the conservative argument
was always look people are born with all
sorts of desires it's a fallen world and
some of them you got to repress
but the left said no that's awful that's
retrograde that's terrible
now they seem to be endorsing it
furthermore they're saying these
pedophiles need to go to therapy to try
to mitigate their desires to try to
change their desires
that's just conversion therapy
conversion therapy isn't a real thing
it's a slogan that the left has put on
various psychological and spiritual
programs to try to get people who have
unwanted sexual desires to be able to
repress them somewhat or to mitigate
them or to change them
but they're endorsing that now for the
pedos well why well because pedophilia
is especially bad okay sure but i
thought the argument that you were
making is that it is immoral and unjust
to force someone to repress their urges
and to force someone to try to change
their urges when you can't change those
urges by golly because they're immutable
and it's a sexual orientation so you
told me it was wrong to do that but now
you're saying it's right to do that in
some cases why is it right to do that in
some cases well because
certain sexual desires are simply wrong
michael
is what they're saying
huh
interesting because that's not the art
and by the way i'm not i'm not just uh
picking on the homosexuals here
or they're transgenderists or whatever
i'm talking about the whole sexual
revolution we were told
we weren't alive i wasn't alive back
then but you can see it in the
literature
in the 1960s 1970s
that all sorts of sexual urges need to
be indulged you're urged to have sex
before marriage you're urged to have sex
with multiple people you're urged to all
of these urges they just you can't
stifle a man it's free love come on just
let it out otherwise you're going to
explode no
no of course that was never true
and only because we're taking this issue
to the most logical extreme here
do we see
why that's not true i kind of like the
article i know sorry i don't think that
usa today meant the article to be liked
by
conservatives such as us but i think
they make a very conservative point hey
you
[Music]
it's nice to be with you nice to see you
i'm glad we could spend this time
together if you want to spend more time
together
ring my bell
that's right
ring my bell ll ring my bell you will
get the notifications you can also head
on over to apple podcast spotify
stitcher google play wherever you get
your audio podcast subscribe to the
michael knowles show
m-i-c-h-a-e-l-k-n-w-l-e-s space s-h-o-w
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]